ils encourent et maurepas bénéficieront
d'un taux de ce nouveau centre
aqualudique le contrat de délégation de
service public vient d'être signé un
soulagement pour le maire de maurepas
qui attend ce projet depuis cinq ans on
arrive au bout d'un long projet qui
avait démarré depuis 2015
on a perdu du temps à cause de conflits
politiques inutiles 1 2 ans il aurait pu
être livré beaucoup plus tôt voilà
aujourd'hui la finalité est là on
propose aux élans courtois comme
occasion un équipement ludique un centre
aqualudique composé de plusieurs espaces
santé et bien-être qui sera accessible
pour les habitants des deux communes un
projet qui se veut ambitieux et qui veut
moderniser les équipements sportifs de
la ville
aujourd'hui le résultat est là ça va
être aussi certainement un modèle aussi
des d'expérimentation parce que beaucoup
de villes dans en france on ce problème
il ya une obsolescence aujourd'hui du
patrimoine notamment en ce qui concerne
d'équipement des piscines caste alias
est le nom de ce centre aqualudique un
projet intercommunal qui s'adapte à
l'environnement le chantier va durer 21
mois
donc avec une livraison prévue en avril
on a à peu près 140 mille heures de
travail sur ce chantier en effectif de
pointe vous avez raison on va être à peu
près une petite centaine à peu près 90
personnes on a prévu ou elle a un
effectif de points donc ça va faire du
monde sur ce site fictivement mais voilà
pour un bel ouvrage à la fin les gros
travaux commenceront dans six mois coût
de cette réalisation un peu plus de 24
millions d'euros